[Music]
if you love Disney princesses as much as
we do you're going to go gaga over this
wicked fan art wash until the end to see
how different artists around the world
portray our favorite princesses you'll
hardly be able to recognize Rapunzel
looking for something new and exciting
to watch why not check out our friends
over at crafty hackers they'll teach you
how to recycle old objects into new and
improved ones now let's jump right into
alternate stories of Disney princesses
in other countries mogera it's no secret
that the feisty mogera has a wicked
backbone shooting rocks which is why
Hercules himself fell in love with her
despite all of this smeg is still one of
the most underrated Disney Princesses of
all time while she's originally from a
Greek background a tumblr artist by the
name of let there be doodles decided to
transform her into an ancient Egyptian
in order to make her look the part he
chose to change her small purple eyes
into wide dark brown eyes in addition he
also added some dramatic eyeliner and
eyeshadow to give her that edgy look she
deserves
mogera 'he's new look was then completed
with a short haircut and egyptian
garments all in all it's safe to say
that mogera is rocking her attire while
it would be interesting to see her
appear in an Egyptian Disney movie we do
love her just the way she is in Hercules
Elsa Elsa is one of the most loved
Disney Princesses of all time and it
isn't hard to see why after all the girl
has magical powers
Elsa's character was inspired by a
Danish author Hans Christian Andersen's
story The Snow Queen
however Elsa's ethnicity is said to be
Norwegian with the help of two amazing
artists Elsa's light hair and pale skin
were transformed to tumblr artists who
go by the names of Julia J m15 and a
knocko - art pulled their talents
together to create an African version of
Elsa to do so they darkened her skin
giving it a beautiful ebony glow they
also changed her eyes from blue to brown
and gave her hair a more silvery tone
Wabo Elsa's are beautiful in their own
way this rendition is simply gorgeous
are you shocked by this dramatic
transformation if so wait until you see
what princess Belle has in store for you
Merida Francis Merida of dunbroch isn't
someone you want to mess with and this
is because she's quick on her feet and
knows how to string a bow and arrow this
independent princess house from Scotland
which is why it's usually hard to
understand what she's saying
once again tumblr artist julia j m15
decided to give this disney princess a
wicked makeover
this time however she chose to reimagine
her as biracial Merida usually has
flaming red hair
ample freckles pale skin and bright
green eyes a light dusting of freckles
and dark brown curly hair all in all
it's easy to see that this is Merida
what isn't easy though is choosing which
version we like best Jane Porter
Tarzan's Jane Porter will always hold a
special place in our hearts not only is
she intelligent and adventurous she's
also extremely kind jane is said to be
from an English background which would
explain her overall look she can easily
be recognized by her long brown hair
wide turquoise eyes thin lips and
overall elegance an unknown artist from
clip D uploaded a number of reimagined
Disney Princesses on line one of them
being the Chinese version of Jane in
order to achieve the transformation the
artist changed
Jane's brown hair to black he also
shortened her long hair and pinned it
into a bun her peach skin was swapped
for a light beige the artist also
narrowed her eyes and changed their
colour from turquoise to black to
finalize the look Jane's clothing was
swapped for a traditional Chinese gown
can you recognize Jane after this
startling makeover Hui sure can't onna
Princess Anna of arendelle is a sweet
yet courageous character who always does
the right thing just like her big sister
Elsa her ethnicity is inspired by the
Norwegian people Anna is easily
recognized by her auburn hair blue eyes
button nose and light skin her
appearance was altered by an unknown
clip the artist who seems to have
transformed her into an Italian princess
Ana's Auburn braided pigtails were
swapped for a dark brown color her blue
eyes were then changed to a light hazel
her peachy skin was bronzed over and her
eyes were slanted downwards Princess
Anna no longer looks Norwegian but
that's not necessarily a bad thing
in other words both of these versions
are simply adorable
Esmeralda The Hunchback of Notre Dom
isn't always the easiest Disney movie to
watch however if there's one character
who brightens up the pot its Esmeralda I
could do this you wouldn't find me
dancing in the streets for coin this
gorgeous tipsy woman might have a few
tricks up her sleeve but in the end she
was a heart of gold
since this movie takes place in France
many of us believe Esmeralda to be a
French descent however she is actually
half French half Romanian an unknown
clip D artist transformed her into a
middle-eastern beauty to do this he
swapped her bright green eyes for light
brown ones and gave them a new angle her
black hair was pulled back and covered
however a few strands of brown hair
still peek through perhaps the biggest
change in her appearance is her new
outfit which looks sophisticated and
breezy Ariel The Little Mermaid is a
fairy tell us oldest time it was written
by Danish author Hans Christian Andersen
over 100 years ago however it was
revamped from generation to generation
four centuries before that Disney's
Little Mermaid is very different than
its original however it still occurs off
the coasts of Denmark Princess Ariel is
easily recognized by her dark red hair
fair skin and big blue eyes oh and her
green tell of course an unknown clip d
artists chose to give her a very special
transformation
Ariel's skin was darkened by the artist
as was her red hair her blue eyes were
swapped for green ones and some jewels
were added to her hairline the Danish
Ariel we all know was then transformed
into an Indian Ariel both versions of
our favourite mermaid are absolutely
stunning don't you agree
jasmine jasmine is by far one of the
most awesome Disney Princesses of all
time not only does she speak her mind
and take risks she also shows how to be
herself despite what others expect from
her and you'll fear
so an unknown clip d artist chose to
give jasmine and her most faithful
sidekick a startling makeover
jasmine is usually seen wearing her blue
outfit chunky earrings and a jewel
encrusted headband
however the artist behind this
transformation chose to replace these
items with African jewelry Jasmine's
long black hair nose eye shape and skin
tone was changed making way for a
dramatic makeover her hair was cut short
and left natural and her outfit was
swapped for a traditional African canoe
Jasmine wasn't the only one to undergo a
transformation though Roz she was
usually a tiger was transformed into a
big and beautiful lion Belle
Princess Belle is a calm and intelligent
character who wasn't looking for love
fortunately life had something else in
store for her Belle might be beautiful
but she doesn't have a shallow bone in
her body she's from a small French
village and she's known as one of the
most gorgeous women in the ten mile
radius a tumblr artist by the name of
let there be doodles chose to reimagine
Belle in a Middle Eastern light and his
efforts paid off Belle's chestnut brown
hair and eyes were changed to dark brown
in addition her pale skin was also
darkened a few shades as was her
lipstick Belle's eyebrows were thickened
and narrow downwards which sort of gives
her a Princess Jasmine vibe if this
transformation shocks you wait until you
see what Cinderella looks like snow
white snow white and the seven dwarfs
might be an excellent Disney movie but
it can sometimes be a little scary after
all Snow White is chased into the forest
by a huntsman who plans to end her young
life it may be hard to imagine Snow
White looking any other way but tumblr
artists let there be doodles had no
issues reimagine a ting her the artist
chose to give the fair Snow White a
Spanish look and we're glad that he did
the young princesses white skin received
a sunkissed glow
her hazel eyes were darkened and makeup
was added to her face her hair was
slightly curled and pulled back by a
gorgeous red flower and finally her
dress was transformed into a wine red
Spanish gown this makeover makes snow
white look 10 years older than she
really is Aurora
tumblr artists let there be doodles is
added again
and this time he's fixed his gaze on
Princess Aurora Sleeping Beauty is one
of the most well known Disney Princesses
of all time which is why she deserves a
makeover of her own Aurora is known for
having long blonde hair purple eyes pink
lips and an elegant schoolgirl attire
let there be doodles completely revamped
her style by giving her puppy sleeves
and a deeper neckline on top of this the
artist also changed
Aurora's Caucasian background to an
African one her hair was swapped for
dark brown dreads and her purple eyes
took on a light hazel tone Aurora's
overall look may have drastically
changed but one thing remains the same
she's still as beautiful as ever
tiana princess tiana is gorgeous beyond
belief suppose you want a kiss but this
doesn't disqualify her from getting a
makeover of her own the princess in the
frog star grew up in New Orleans and
belongs to an african-american
background artist let there be doodles
decided to give Tiana a completely
different look which prompted him to
turn her into a Japanese princess plot
see on his hairstyle mostly stayed the
same her hair was darkened and her curls
were straightened out her dark hair was
switched for at and beige and her eyes
were narrowed out and darkened as well
to make the transformation all the more
impressive
Tiana's dress was turned into a pink
kimono is this makeover something or
what we're having a hard time picking a
favorite that's for sure
Pocahontas if there's one Disney movie
we don't get tired of watching its
Pocahontas this beautifully animated
movie gave birth to one of these
strongest female characters ever
Pocahontas is beautiful kind and tough
making her a force to be reckoned with
once again tumblr artists let there be
doodles reimagined our favorite Disney
Princess in a very fitting way
Pocahontas who is of Native American
descent was transformed into a Hawaiian
beauty her dark hair stayed the same
shade however some wave was added to it
the princess his eyes were rounded out
as was her chin on top of that her skin
tone was lightened by a few shades and
her trademark necklace was swapped for a
seashell one can you recognize
Pocahontas from this picture or is the
makeover far too drastic move on if
there's one Disney princess who isn't
afraid to take on the world its Mulan
this selfless character for her life and
honor
on the line to stop her father from
having to go to war Mulan is a Chinese
princess who is typically seen wearing a
kippah
and trying to actually be like however
the brave young girl prefers to dress in
less restrictive clothing tumblr artists
let every doodles chose to reimagine
Mulan as a Native American woman and his
rendition of hers absolutely gorgeous
Milan's black hair was tied into two
long braids and adorned by a white
feather she was given tribal clothing
darker skin around her eyes and wider
lips
all in all Milan looks like a completely
different person Cinderella perhaps one
of let there be doodles most drastic
transformations is the one befits by
Cinderella this princess is said to live
somewhere in France which would explain
her pale complexion and blond hair the
artist behind this transformation
decided to turn Cinderella into a Geisha
Cinderella's blond hair became black and
her face was painted white with
highlights of red makeup her eyes were
narrowed and changed to a black color to
complete her new look her dress was
turned into a gorgeous kimono can you
recognize this princess at first glance
rapunzel last but not least is the
much-anticipated Rapunzel this Disney
Princess is typically seen wearing her
pink dress and long blonde hair you all
tired from choosing his bed man all over
the place however let there be doodles
had something different plans for her
her dress was transformed into a flower
and broidered Spanish gown her blonde
hair was darkened to brown as were her
green eyes to make her transformation
more legitimate a great number of
flowers were added to her hair are you
totally in love with these
transformations if so let us know which
Disney Princess you thought looks the
best in the comments before you go don't
forget to check out crafty hackers if
you love Disney you'll absolutely love
all Disney DIY videos that'll help you
turn your everyday objects into Disney
themed clothing make sure you give them
a big thumbs up and that's a wrap don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more amazing
content thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]